we're so used to thinking of Jesus as a
divinity whom we accept or reject on the
basis of faith that were apt to miss a
far more relevant detail that he was an
extremely acute philosopher whose rules
on human conduct maintain a deep and
ongoing applicability one of the most
salient of his lessons comes in chapter
8 of the Gospel of st. John Jesus has
recently come down from Galilee to
Jerusalem when some Pharisees members of
a sect focused on precise adherence to
Jewish tradition and law present him
with a married woman whom they have
called having sex with someone other
than her husband teacher they asked him
this woman was caught in the very act of
committing adultery in our law Moses
commanded that such a woman must be
stoned to death now what do you say
Jesus is being edged into a trap will he
say that it's completely fine to have an
affair or will the mild-mannered
preacher of love and forgiveness turn
out to be just as strict about legal
matters as the Jewish authorities he
like to criticize Jesus makes a deft
move he doesn't categorically deny the
mob the right to stone the woman to
death but he adds one apparently small
but in practice epochal caveat to this
right they can kill and destroy her to
their heart's content if they can be
absolutely sure that they have first
satisfied one crucial criteria that they
have never done anything wrong
themselves importantly by this Jesus
doesn't mean if they've never slept
around outside of their marriage he
means if they've never done anything
wrong at all whatsoever across any area
of their lives only absolute moral
purity grants us the right to be vicious
high-handed an unsparing towards
transgressors an important principle of
ethics is being introduced we are to be
counted as properly innocent not when we
are blameless in this or that area but
when we have done nothing wrong
whatsoever at any point and in any
context Jesus response to the Pharisees
with what have become immortal
let him who is without sin cast the
first stone
the mob understanding the rebuke put
down their projectiles and the terrified
woman is spared the real target of this
story is a perennial problem in the
human soul self-righteousness
self-righteousness is that degenerate
outgrowth of something that's otherwise
extremely valuable a desire to be in the
right the problem is that being in the
right in some areas
has a fateful tendency to lead us to see
ourselves as morally blameless across
our entire lives and therefore
encourages a particular
mean-spiritedness and inhumanity towards
those who transgress in situations where
we have been good jesus' point is that
the surest way to be kind is not to take
pride in never having done a particular
species of wrong it lies in seeing that
inevitably we too have been foolish and
cruel at other moments and in using that
knowledge to foster compassion towards
those whom it lies in our powers to as
it were stone a world in which we keep
our own wrongs firmly in mind becomes
paradoxically a properly virtuous and
humane place
if you liked this film please subscribe
to our channel and click the Bell icon
to turn on notifications our great
thinkers book collects some of the most
important ideas from eastern and western
culture from across history exploring
what they can offer us in the 21st
century